good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-12ex
object class
explained
special containment procedures
non-applicable the original file for
scp-12vx has been deleted due to
containing fabricated evidence and to
inhibit attempts to waste foundation
resources in replicating the tests the
previous warning on this file which read
this file must not be read in the dark
please ensure your environment is
sufficiently well lit before proceeding
may be disregarded
description
scp-12ex is the paranoid sensation that
one is being stalked by some form of
unseen malicious entity typically up one
or more flights of stairs in low light
conditions
scp-12vx is common in children and teens
and may persist until adulthood it is
more prevalent in western cultures
primarily being experienced in suburban
settings before its redesignation as
explained scp-12ex refer to malevolent
entities which manifest in close
proximity to a human target in dark and
poorly lit areas when the subject is
alone
the previous iteration further clarified
approximately one-third of humans
possess an innate ability to sense the
presence of their scp-12ex
there was no data to support this claim
through neural imaging and interviews
with affected persons in recent years
scp-12vx has been proven to be merely a
combination of various fears such as
pterophobia and climacophobia further
the sensation can be exacerbated by the
consumption of horror media it is likely
due to this fact that the falsified
document stated scp-12 appear with more
regularity near persons actively
panicking or who are feeling fearful and
paranoid it is unknown why these persons
are seemingly preferred but it should be
noted that those which dwell on thoughts
pertaining to their scp-12 instances
coincide with said instances presenting
with higher degrees of clarity and
definition while under indirect
observation
history
though never regarded with any
credibility throughout the foundation's
existence
scp-12ex was proposed as an avenue of
research by dr theodore richardson he
posited the existence of a class of
undetectable entities responsible for
scp-12vx
due to the prevalence of discussion
regarding the sensation throughout
various forums and social media
platforms the decision was made to allow
dr richardson to begin investigating the
phenomena
despite repeated tests purporting to
document the existence of malicious
entities through the use of pressure
plates laser detection and sonar imagery
all documentation was found to contain
no concrete evidence
regarding the supposed physicality of
the entities dr richardson writes that
they are mostly humanoid though are
unbound by human physiology when it
comes to ambulation and range of motion
being able to twist and contort their
frames into any desired position or
assuming a quadrupedal gate the
contortion is mainly used to remain
unseen for example by compressing its
frame in order to slip beneath a bed
frame or hide behind obstructions during
one observation an scp-12 manifestation
stretched its limbs to brace itself
between two opposing walls staying well
above its target's line of sight as it
stalked her in her home
the project was forcibly disbanded by
the site director following several
complaints from the participating
d-class subjects who each voluntarily
left the project due to stress caused by
dr richardson's mental state as he
developed a debilitating fear of the
dark on the night preceding the
project's disbandment where three
foundation lives were lost in an
unrelated incident dr richardson
remarked in his personal journal they
know we can see them
richardson was placed on paid leave and
his documentation was put on hold for
review two days later dr richardson's
neighborhood experienced a power outage
he dialed the site's emergency response
number but was not present on the other
end of the line when the call connected
within minutes local police were called
over the sounds of struggle coming from
the home agent justine locke is
dispatched to investigate
begin log
the body cam activates as agent lock
exits her vehicle emergency lights are
present throughout the neighborhood as
public servants attend to
inconsequential crises that have arisen
during the blackout as she crosses the
street a squad car rounds the corner
lights activated and stops in front of
the house locke introduces herself with
her federal credentials the officer
exits his vehicle and identifies himself
as oliver hannity and explains he is
responding to a possible domestic
dispute
the pair approached the stairs leading
to the front door
crunching glass is hurt looking down a
pair of spectacles can be seen underfoot
before the bottommost step luck takes
point hannity follows her up the stairs
the curtains are drawn and with the
exception of the flickering of a
flashlight coming from a room on the
second floor the house is dark lock
rings the doorbell and hannity loudly
declares their presence
they receive no response
upon knocking it it becomes apparent
that the front door is slightly ajar the
pair enter hannity draws his weapon
turning on her flashlight lock reveals a
living room in mild disarray the sofa is
notably crooked with the far end being
forcibly shoved aside toward a door to
the rear of the room leading to the
kitchen a glass table that had
presumably sat center of the room had
been wholly upended and cast aside
shattered the recliner sitting opposite
the couch lay on its back near the front
door in addition there appeared to have
been an attempt to set the home ablaze a
blackened trail of burnt carpet fibers
streaked through the destruction
beginning at the front door and leading
towards the stairway leading up stairs
to their right
it is as lock kneels to investigate this
trail when a woman sobbing can be heard
from above
the two cautiously approached the
stairway hannity identifies himself
again as a police officer eliciting no
response from the woman they ascend the
first few stairs leading to the landing
stepping over the fractured burnt
remains of a cell phone
it becomes apparent as they climb that
the sobbing is emanating from a room
near the end of the hall the door is a
jar lock and hannity advance at a crawl
there is a loud inhuman groaning and the
sobs rapidly turn into frenzied shrieks
the pair quicken their approach the
screams cut off just as lock extends a
hand and carefully opens the door
it is the richardson's bedroom it is
largely undisturbed unlike the damage
witnessed downstairs save for the mess
of sheets on the mattress a large
comforter bundled tightly lay hanging
off the foot of the bed twisting around
and trailing the floor underneath
a full canvas of the home revealed that
neither dr richardson nor his wife
were present
end log
the following is a list of collected
evidence from the residents
one pair of reading glasses belonging to
dr richardson crushed
4 cubic centimeters of burnt carpet no
chemical markers could be found to
indicate fuel type
one personal cell phone burnt and
destroyed verified to have made the
emergency call
and one floral comforter the bottom of
which was shredded and wet with an
unidentified clear fluid
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
lily
the almighty
fish gav the clumsy containment
specialist
spooky aqua
jaby
pure osmium
sciodio demnatus
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbeage
longinus
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you